you
okay this is the Halloween gambit arena
a themed tournament one-minute chess 30
minutes of one-minute chest black to
move and that was the starting position
my opponent is quickly giving the
material back castling I'm ready to jump
into d5 by picking up that bishop maybe
I don't want him hmm
let's go here bishop here I have Knight
f4 I have that too I also had Bishop f3
no this is this is winning cuz I could
take the bishop now I just want some
trades there hmm
I'm okay with this two minor pieces
versus the rook I have excellent
coordination the King secured towards
the center
and maybe I could camp out on this
square soon I need to crack over here
they could still push on the rook I
almost went with the wrong pawn down on
time and I'll and a fork how about d5
and then oh okay rook takes I would have
rook takes rook should have gone with
bishop check maybe that's very helpful
now we're entering just get that King
out of there getting a lot of material
now my King has some security why did I
do that that was silly
Tyrael though should be able to go fast
no stalemates oh no I'm done on time all
I do is take the rook oh man oh man I
was clicking like crazy so many illegal
most how did I not win that ah awful Oh
No
ah man that was that was that was too
hard to lose I don't know
ah my king my king got a little bit too
crazy that's what it was he got a little
bit too crazy yeah I put my king in a
spot where he could be checked like
crazy and he didn't have security ah man
I want to keep back so bad ah alright
let's just take a look for a second I'm
thinking it this is king of the hill no
it's not it's just regular chess this
guy is going into the think tank once
castle oh man all I had to do at least
to hold the drawers just take the rook
back to tournament I got it - alright
okay I'm gonna take the night and I'm
gonna go with this variation once more
on takes knight Knight takes here Queen
to one of those two I think works that
was kind of weird how did that queenside
castle I have this check and then Queen
takes pawn just have to watch out for an
F for pre move so I'm off upon I'll play
some games where I just run away with my
knight and I won't play Bishop to b4
just for some variety but uh you know
I'd save him and prepare to double and
rake the whole fourth-ranked prevents a
lot of the white pawns from moving I'm
definitely open to trading let's get my
king up and maybe a b4 move at some
point just walking a little bit of a
tightrope this is a threat now just
shielding the King off who they ran
right into a fork on takes next let's
just secure here and then hunt these
pawns down big time edge
they just mount slipped they're down on
time back to Terman all right I got four
I'm on page 245 players here okay who's
up top VIN VIN Chernobyl Romeo zanbato
is in second for my first opponent all
right here we go so I guess I'll give it
a go with just running away saving the
piece and try to break down the center
now I have that square covered mmm
I'll try to get in a queenside castle
they could take here though that would
have been really good though white
squares would have been weakened Bishop
b5 all right now this is excellent let's
chase the Queen away and okay I'm
gaining valuable tempo many moves here
uh-oh that's a problem incoming Queen f3
the whole farm is falling and that was a
bit of a help mate oh and we have
another pairing right away playing on
the white end now let's go d4 and d5 and
I guess we're going to points right at
f7 try to target that so I have a bit of
a pond storm going on in the center I
think yeah d5 is a good move I don't
want to give up a 5 for the D pawn I
want to try to play with these two
opponent is giving me some material back
now I am just ok it's even material but
I have a huge lead in development and I
was ready to pick off another pawn I
guess we could do something as simple as
double on the F file and then this guy
is bound to fall
let's move forward throw a punch bishop
block I could take because they're in a
pin okay and now in the end we have a
fork getting some more material I'm up
upon soon to be up the exchange it's
just back up big-time edge 11 under 10
let's just get a flight square I want to
see one of the rooks actually I could
have I could have captured that rook
because he was completely free it really
shouldn't matter much though the clock
situation there down on time
determined all right I got 12 16 is in
first 16 with fire 14 13 12 12 plenty of
time left in this Halloween gambit arena
21 seconds 21 21 alrighty
oh I got to get him back did I have
white against him the first time it's
Queen D for a move I could do this I
want to see white work a little bit
harder let me give this check isn't that
uncomfortable I'm tempted to take with
the pawn but let's just secure the
bishop
a little bit awkward night here I just
back up yeah
let's target this guy hmm flight squares
okay this should be a little bit awkward
my bishop breathing down the queenside
hmm I don't want to give away this
bishop so soon all right I want to chase
that night away I want the beep on I'm
not playing this well one rook off I
guess they're going to have a very
active rook king up you go up what with
the king all right I think they should
have stepped up because I didn't have
this move now I need to get here yeah
it's a good move they're getting my C
pawn
maybe I should have given a check is
this going to be another time burning
game hmm why did I do
this
gotta track that
on down oh no not another time burning
game oh no I don't have much time
take my rook I guess there's gonna be a
draw
I draw man keeps extinguishing my fire
zanbato the fire extinguisher the who's
in first I thought somebody had 31 on
reading things wrong 20 is in 1st 2017
14 I'm at 14 and d4e 5 and I learned
last time that this move can be met with
d5 so I'm saving myself a move now and
I'll be looking for an f5 move really
soon like right now if allowed Bishop f5
might be a move maybe I go caveman-style
to try and flush this guy away let's try
it the knight moves and then we have f5
I'm gaining a lot of space I have a
development edge as well and this is a
really invasive piece and this Knight is
cooked
no h4 is going down let's take what the
pond keep this night in the pinned you
can look for an e6 or f6 break I'll keep
the pen Queen h5 ok let's keep that pawn
duo Queen on h5 is in a really strong
piece I'll go with this on pawn takes I
have Queen h5 and I guess maybe this
let's go here connect it passed pawn
they don't have time little pin first
yeah they don't have any time try to
break down this structure just return
the Queen no time
determine 2421 1716 gotta fight my way
back I need another win to get that fire
I got to stay away from him 24:21 1749
players in this one less than 17 to go
okay all righty
hmm an on capture am I not just up upon
then I'm gonna return okay that's
interesting so I'm just up a pond let's
go here I'm anticipating that this night
will be targeted I want to reinforce
this point let's go here could I
captured their first I don't know it
ship takes bishop yeah let's take here I
don't want to if I took like this then
this square was gonna be too much so
he's dumb hang on to this pawn right row
takes I have e5 I still have that tactic
I have to be careful of f2 hmm that's a
good move let's still go with this I
want to make sure that this pawn
survives so let's keep my Bishop around
to watch over them and I guess my
bishops gonna be challenged soon I have
Queen to b5 not on that move maybe I
still do no I don't I don't even want to
allow Queen takes f2 Knight g4 stuff I
want the Knights exchanged
I want my Bishop on d5 and apone on c4
chase the Queen away and then how about
this maybe a step closer to having this
happen Knight trade watch out for Knight
f4 that will really really hurt okay
there should be something for me here
you can't take because I'm on the
look at the end so I could plant my
knight here he probably has to go nope
dropped out I don't have any time back
to tournament 2424 top guy slipped up
top to slipped up twenty fours 24 with
fire I have fire now at 18 and I'm in
fifth let's then have to go 14 and
change okay Chris p99
alright let's take and we'll do another
one where I run away and you know what
you know I'm gonna try in that last game
just how my opponent uh just how my
opponent played Bishop c5 I think I want
to give that a go I think how I replied
is best to return the night they
resigned back determine that was a quick
one at 22 they were losing their Queen
there yeah I think he just finished yeah
I think we're gonna get paired up myself
in VIN VIN yes so a Bishop c5 Knight
here I think is best
oh no all right so did I play him in
round one no let's let's give this Czech
Bishop block I have here okay let's play
with the bishop pair I guess huh let's
just throw a quick punch turn the Bishop
to e3 I want to maintain this structure
kick the night away
five and now he doesn't have this square
whoo
hmm okay let's let's hang tight here
that night is not a good piece I want to
keep one rook on yeah let's play on this
wing this is a good pawn structure let's
shoot this night away am I being too
inconvenience doing this I'm still gonna
yeah I am
ah man okay I didn't realize that there
was Bishop takes c3 okay I have a good
good harmony between my structure and
Bishop the rook doesn't have any entry
points where even on time and they did
well just then to target f3 I'm on the
b6 pawn
wow I spent too much time just then too
much time I'm gonna give some checks oh
man
yeah they're getting my last pawn can't
win this could only lose it
Oh draw oh man
okay less than 12 we have a huge tie for
first okay
the only one with fires and bottom one
two three five way tie for first with 24
11 minutes 11 seconds okay yeah I'm
gonna try this I think um this reminds
me of some morphe game I believe playing
his black more if he had black yeah just
developing I think best again is Knight
to f3 but I think most players would
take here no okay that's interesting so
white is giving up a piece one way or
the other they want to play it
sacrificing something I got to get rid
of this Bishop he's too strong as I
didn't want to go to this square because
of night here I covered this square that
wasn't my intention but hmm that's
interesting let's go here I could grab a
tempo against the Queen soon no right
there let's try this it's ready to take
the Queen width Chuck it's the big plan
to be careful of this square also here I
have 92 let's not forget about 92 well
they're really going into the think tank
and I got a take I guess and I think I
should take this pawn he's important
yeah no I should be able to cover stuff
right here and let's secure my Bishop
I'm still within checking distance okay
this I think makes it a little bit
easier because I could find some safe
squares for my pieces by Bishop in
particular he cannot be dislodged
um let's just keep this I will I will be
capturing at some point connected passer
I could just get pushing right away I'm
controlling the promotion square yeah
let's get this pawn and they resigned
back determine 32 26 26 I still don't
have fire only three fours 11 games only
three three fours less than nine ah men
okay okay here's my chance this is the
pack leader let's throw this at him see
how he reacts okay and now we're gonna
go for a quick f2 strike this is the
idea one of the ideas okay so we're
gonna hang out at the dark square Bishop
and hope he is a pain yeah we're gonna
keep him planted right here or try to at
least a g4 it could go here it's Castle
this Bishop stopping castling on in both
both directions pointing at B - now on
d4 what I have to do on d4 to break this
down I'm running into these temp tempo
gaining moves my bishops need to breathe
and they're not breathing my rooks
activated my dark square Bishop needs to
do something else I could take that h4
pawn a million times I'm on the h2
square let's just get rid of that night
let's grab another pond let's look for a
check here
just back up stay ahead on the clock and
I think everything should be alright so
I need to take the beep on now okay the
night has to recapture I'm getting
another one I'm allowing some activity
though let's get back here let's just
keep it really simple
stop this pond from moving I should
probably get these guys running huh I
think that's a good start
Bishop check okay and get that King out
of there and maybe the rook here yeah
rook check rook check our pond check get
the pawns rolling with check yeah okay
this is this is pushing through the
bishop is not playing they're down on
time in fact back to tournament they
took a hit 32 28 28 they're out of fire
and I am just four back less than 751
players in this
okay let's go with the d4 and e5 this is
the way forward if they grab the knight
gotta get another phone involved be
taking with the F pawn all right let's
see if I could induce some weaknesses
pawn takes pawn Queen f7 let's continue
to push in the center space space
invaders okay there should be five
Bishop c4 threatening million one how do
you defend that nine eight six I take
him oh there isn't a good defense we got
me coming up no the knight can't block
the Queen has to block they resigned
back to tournament that was a quick win
thirty two thirty two three thirty twos
I have fire less than six
we're getting there
we are definitely getting there five
minutes ten seconds ambato is in a game
against trackpad VIN VIN guy who is in
second
okay d4 I don't know why I hesitated as
much as I did just then okay okay last
time we played it was a draw okay and
yeah in that last game I had I'm not
playing this well hmmm let's get a
flight square I guess I think I thought
Knight a5 was the idea with that gotta
go here night before Queen here's watch
over that square
they just mouse lifts all right oh I
just dropped my bishop don't take my
bishop they didn't take my bishop thank
you take my bishop now mypods killing
the knight he's a superstar right here
on d5 a superstar that's a first not
sure where that one came from but he's a
superstar I hope to use that one more
often if I if I somehow work that went
into the commentary and then stop using
it someone someone will say when you're
gonna start saying I don't know what I'm
talking about
start saying why don't you say superstar
anymore I'm actually reminded someone
left a comment recently they said you
don't say for karu ski anymore
I said I'll have to work that one back
in the commentary so there you go
I forget the person's name I should not
be locking things down like this guys
have to try to play over here there we
go
I'm entering
entering grabbing upon they don't have
any time
dr. tournament I've no idea what I
rambled on about just then okay I have a
lead that's what I know
36 with fire I'm up to overs ambato
let's grab the night and run away
I guess we'll try for d6 you got to
undermine this this points
don't fall for a mate in one yeah yeah
man that's pretty scary I'm gonna take
here Wow
man I'm really backed up I had Knight
takes pawn Knight takes pawn on the
Queen miss that okay well I am having no
issues now I'm up a clean piece okay
they stole a pawn for it but yeah my
king there's no issue it's my king now I
have 95 Bishop to g4 some nice advancing
moves Ritz tempo with attack let's go
for it now get that light square bishop
yeah oh actually I was on the Queen they
resigned back to termined for tea with
fire 34 34 28 less than two oh he just
finished we're gonna get paired up he
has to know he has fire so if he beats
me he'd go right past me
are we gonna get paired up
I wouldn't mind us not getting paired up
for a few more seconds that way I have
known a FRA tactic up available yeah oh
wait I could I could actually wait a few
more seconds to get my first move in hmm
let's see
I could have waited longer but uh
I was a bit nervous that I might
overstep the the time how bad would that
be place the clock and then I don't even
get the game in night i forfeit that's
what I was fearing let's get a flight
square oh no it's gonna hurt me or is he
alright give me uh give me the file and
I'm giving you a target you got that guy
if you want him they don't want him
clean trade a clean trade this isn't any
good
I want my king to weasel over here
that's a pretty static structure I
should be able to break things down over
here with c5 rook b5 to support this now
there goes my pawn but there goes their
beep on and where's their King position
gimme connected passers
I'm not sure what this this rook is
doing over here
I could take in my rooks or defending c3
there might be some a fancy mating net
no aren't you are you scared
shouldn't you be scared I think they
should be scared yes you should be
scared that's mate
oh there's no time anyhow and ugh and
the tournament clock back to tournament
yeah two rooks tactical one rook
technical there was still some tricks
there all right I hate I was able to
come back definitely some speed bumps a
speed bump right out of the gate and
then a couple drawers in there if I'm
not mistaken
yeah 40 37 34 31 this is page one San
Bato second VIN VIN third and just out
of podium land trackpad alright let's
see the other pages page two three four
five and six
alrighty
to the fifty three of you could games
all